oh okay we're doing one more
okay hopefully i remember what to do is
white
man so i've
i really like the position is black
so i guess we're doing one more
and now i have to weather the storm of a
a traxler
oh dear
i hope i remember what to do i mean
i think it's pretty self-explanatory
so i take i take the rook
and d5 we'll see what advanced play is
it might be different
and i'm supposed to take and then play
d6 i think it's v6
yeah it just has the same line
it's just weird having the oh queen
takes oh
oh no
i don't know what to do here because
there is pawn takes but queen ticks
i assume see
oh no i foster's prepared like probably
prepared beyond this too
[Music]
okay i'll try and be brave
so i am up a rook
i feel like taking the bishop is
poisonous because 94
but maybe it's playable i don't know
wait what happened in our game like i
oh yeah it takes and then king takes
and then there is queen f1
but now the i guess the queen is a
better place kind of
i feel like i'm gonna lose really
quickly here
i'm so scared
i might as well take and just be up a
rook and a bishop and
but 94
wow i don't know what to do
i was hoping to be the first one to
deviate
okay let's say com i know like engine
says white's better here but
it's obviously not so obvious
this move is logical like preventing 94
prospects
the problem is bishop g4 living on the
knife's edge
yeah i feel like i'm being slightly
poked
d3 d3 there's pros and cons
because it does give a square for my
queen defends the bishop prevents knight
e4
i think i'll play d3
i'm looking like worst case scenario
i don't even know what the worst case
scenario i lose instantly um
but i think i'm covering like all the
obvious threats
let's play d3 so i'm not taking the
bishop
i'm trying to excel or move king quickly
i'm trying to accelerate my development
four months in a night now
hey congrats on becoming a knight
okay so queen d2 is my original plan i'm
also realizing i could sack my queen and
have two miners and a rook for it but
then knight g4 happens so i think queen
d2
[Music]
is a way to proceed
don't hurt me
okay yeah so the bishop escaped
unscathed
i'm only up a rook i have not a seven
or actually the knight could be useful
like targeting queen
controlling g5
oh this is a kind of a threat
okay but i'm if i play knife seven hit
the queen bishop e2 i take
would be very thrilled to trade queens
and meanwhile queen c's looks like i
play knight c3 let's play this
gotta watch my time too
i'm gonna have a lot of things to
analyze after these games
okay i'm not going to be looking at
chats
um but thanks people subbing oh
psychedelic gazelle subbing for four
months
appreciate that and stephen gray oh
cheering on the
yeah saying something about the knife's
edge
well the knight is no longer on the the
very edge
or the inner intersection of the edges
it's attacking from behind
it just feels really awkward like having
my queen here king's not castle
rook is stuck these pieces undeveloped
but most important thing is i'm not
getting mated and not um
yeah mainly not getting needed not
losing a significant amount of material
either
if queen c6 knight c3 there's some
potential for
um bishop b5
or even knight e5
oh queen c6 95 is an idea
just scared opening the center
so what's so worse that can happen here
the queen has to move
and because of 95 black might be more
inclined to move the queen
to where the pawn is still defended like
this or this
okay so that's logical
[Music]
and now i'm realizing if i play knight
c3 there's crazy move 92
which is terrifying because this is a
mate threat
and taking the knight doesn't solve
anything
but i think i can play this allow knight
e2 and play queen e3
again super terrifying but
i feel like with this opening you have
to learn how to be brave hi eric today i
received my own oh my queen merch hey
hey let's go to chilly south america
thanks man wait really would you be
inclined to celebrate this arrival with
a match
love ya oh maybe
um but let me let me focus here
that's great to hear it shipped to chile
welcome back jimberwood
never been to chile
the merch made it to chile before i made
it to chile
okay so i'm hoping i didn't overlook
anything
i mean the squares around my king are
covered for the most part
this was a main concern it's a cool move
because it obstructs the queen
and unleashes box queen
but it's nice i have a bishop supporting
queen e3
but there's still issues i mean my king
my time
my rooks it's a cool opening because
there's so many lines where the the
white rooks don't come into play
for so long and white needs to survive
like so many moves of just the onslaught
of black pieces
now the dream is to get counter play
like if i can play queen e3 and start
hitting the pawn and put black on the
defense that would be nice
funky fun chess bits yeah speaking of
funky a very funky move
uh that's a cool move actually
i mean my first impression is just to
move back because what else to do
if i wanna i think i should move back
and if takes takes i don't think
i'm getting hurt oh i'm losing the
knight though
[Music]
ooh oh b5 was very resourceful
[Music]
the thing is my month exchange or no i'm
up the
i'm up at rook so if i lose at night i'm
up to exchange so
the black wins some material i gotta do
it
wow
yeah that's i think a strong move
because now my knight
what do i do with my knight
that's actually a really strong move
maybe i can take on e5
i'm just trying yolo
i just want to trade queens
h3 doesn't help 94
actually 94.
maybe 94 takes takes
the problem is bishop e2
[Music]
queen f2 to follow
there's a crazy line where i do lose my
queen
i'm running a very long time here
i lose my queen but
i should i would have
i'd have enough material for it
my rook gets trapped
so terrifying
there's not too many other options
though let's try this
okay so why i'm calculating is takes
takes bishop e2 takes takes takes queen
f2
king here queen takes rookie one takes
takes
and i have three minor pieces for rook
no i don't want to go back the key is a
rook can't move here
because my knight's always controlling
and bishop defends the knight
the other line i can consider is after
takes takes
i have king d3 after queen f2
[Music]
which might be a bit more promising
actually
i mean it looks like insane but the idea
is after takes i keep the rooks
connected
oh that doesn't work though or does it
check
oh maybe it's playable let's try it
so if takes i played vision e3 check i
moved back
have a minute left i have to play like
the rest of my moves just instantly
to avoid flagging
i'm technically a material like i have
enough for the queen it's just my king
is ridiculous
my rooks are yet to be in the game
this is a nice chain of okay let's play
this
actually wondering how i escaped the
checks
oh that's probably a good move this move
it's about to get insane
and not in a good way at least for me
ah my king my king's going on a journey
we should safe travels
da why am i doing this i'm kind of
forced to
what is this
here here my king my trap the rook on
eight
what is this the rook is down trapped
it's about to reach its final
destination
i have 26 seconds though
what is this
this is so funny a king is now my most
aggressive attacking piece
i feel like nigel short kind of
but slightly taller
okay so i'm covering b6 there's no more
checks
there's no castling queen side no castle
fork
actually i'm controlling all the squares
and the king has moved already
i think or has it i don't know
okay let's focus on the current position
though
i'll play this move
oh it's scary i have this
oh no
that wasn't the wisest of choices
i'm about to suffer
c5 was a great move
it's not over yet though hopefully
my king is going to be lonely
this position is so confusing
playing this also obviously this and
this
a lot of threats
yeah i was expecting rook b8
thankfully my king can come back
that's still a little bit unclear
okay so i have
two rooks and a bishop for queen and
something and something
very least i can sack and start
pre-moving stuff
maybe play this move
idea this soon eight seconds
it's so little time man it's gonna be
close though
my king is randomly really safe
protected by bishops
okay so i should win the e pawn
yeah wasn't expecting that move
oh no lock's making another queen
ah
okay i have two seconds left
still fighting
ah
ah ah
good game oh no my rating
good game had fast
that was a really good game oh it's so
close
my king walked all the way up found
shelter
but then my time was dwindling
i was feeling good because i thought i
was winning the pawn but then e3
and i had five seconds left
um that was crazy position and then even
here
i thought there is some hope queen e4 is
a good move though
realizing maybe i should have played
this move keep the queen pinned
is white might maybe slightly worse here
obviously there is no time oh yeah
lights worse
uh because takes and
yeah my rooks are disconnected
okay i'll have to put all these games on
youtube the traxxar is now unbeatable
yeah that game was very nerve-wracking
oh hello to st louis or hello from st
louis
oh there's a poll too good job for
people winning channel points
so we should analyze how well did i play
this
is d3 of acceptable move
oh d3 is not the oh c3 is the best move
which is on my radar but maybe d3 was a
good choice to
avoid prep
bishop e2 i would take
wow this is hard to find
wow so i have to sack my queen and then
somehow
to draw
this is so that tracks are so crazy all
these crazy lines
okay save my knight and then yeah at
this point
well it's still crazy v5 was resourceful
oh i'm losing i'm minus 10 here
wait oh queen b5 check
oh look at this move or look at this
line queen b5
the move i want to play is c4 but then
on poisson
attacking the king and the queen this is
like an
on passant fork
uh how do we combine on poisson and fork
fork passant
double attack
and if king e1 then there's some looks
like there's some windmill
here yeah here here here
or even takes this would be pretty
brutal
oh queen b6
wait what oh the queen goes here to
access later
and again c4 the fork poisson
on the fork
yeah google for croissant have to
to jump on the seo for that
okay um
somehow i got a i survived a queen g4
good move
and then the king yeah the king was
running
so apparently black's better here after
this this or this
but not this queen g6 was logical
but i just trapped the rook
the sc5 was a very good move and then i
kind of freaked out
and i'm losing again but now
oh rook beat his force made in 16.
made in 16 after queen what was his
force mates
so here we'll just play out the engine
line
ooh quiet move and then i have some
spike checks
so this is a force mate
okay that's hard to calculate
um and then
yeah then my bishops got into place and
then i was winning
but then black had to pass e pawn
and then it was apparently equal what is
the graph of this look at this graph
this graph is like the most random kind
of shape thing
yeah okay that was a fun game i'll have
to put both of those on youtube
along with a game from yesterday too so
if you made it this far
in the youtube video there'll probably
be three separate videos
but let me know if you made it this far
let me know if you watch the whole thing
if you have questions stockfish can
probably answer them
and subscribe for more content
maybe like this